a grand farewell for one of Russia's
well-known military bloggers
the body of 40 year old Vlad Lin
tartarsky was brought to the troyo
kurovskaya cemetery Moscow where
hundreds attended
including the head of the Wagner
mercenary group evgeny progressions
KY did a lot so that we could go to
Victory and destroy the enemy thank you
for this we will always remember him he
is a soldier who stays with us whose
voice will always live and speak only
the truth
killing last week President Vladimir
Putin awarded him one of the highest
honors for bravery
under heavy security people waited in
line for hours many of whom Utah tarski
personally he was very enumeric and very
energetic man I think that the best
way to
make his memory of
life is a uh doing this war it was a man
For Whom the victory is was most
important thing in the world his wife
accompanied the coffin as his body was
laid to rest
potarski was a vocal supporter of the
war in Ukraine vedlin tartarsky is being
remembered as a Russian hero and at the
end of his funeral a video of him was
shown where he said Victory will be ours
for now only one person has been
arrested in connection to his murder
while Federal Security Services believe
an organized group was behind the attack
in Saint Petersburg on April 2nd
26 year old Daria tripova is now facing
a possible 20-year prison sentence she
faces charges of terrorism and
possession of explosives accusations
she's denied
security footage from the day of the
attack appears to show tropova carrying
a bus optotarsky that she handed to him
at this Cafe moments later the explosion
happened as the pro-kremlin supporter is
laid to rest officials here have stepped
up their search for others who they
believe may have been involved in this
attack
dorsa Jabari Al Jazeera Moscow